hey I beat it without dying
did you actually do that yeah wait what
the whole game yeah how long did that
take you clearly haven't watched my
video
I saw you doing it but I thought it was
like a meme no I actually like a meme no
death run come click the stream I did I
[ __ ] did it
nice
did you you're playing a concert how did
you patronize because for me I'll play
Your Story game okay
I worked hard for that I don't need a
nice how about this Felix Persona 5 play
through no skip cut scene no skip
90 of the time to [ __ ] falling yeah
how do you not do that you have to plan
your route exactly oh my God are you
like there's your map at all yes
because it would take too long too
otherwise you have to figure out that
did you did you do the oh do you know
when you in Alden ring there's a section
where you can go to like the fire people
what do they call the fire pyromancers
no no the um
bad ending in Elden ring where you
accepted like fire into you oh yeah you
have to jump down all of those things
did you do that no you just jump down
this horrible like jump king-esque
section really of like oh yeah I've seen
that yeah no I'm you avoid those you
have to do like precise platforming
right on Elden ring in a [ __ ] Souls
game in a Souls game precise
it was like it was literally jump King
and meets Alden right now I did it oh it
was it took me like four hours and I
died like 500 times I lost all my money
there's no point even like having an
attachment to it uh I could not get it
yeah that was [ __ ] brutal please play
jumping no no no no no no no no no why
not tell me this already I'm not playing
that's the perfect game for you there's
no cutscene there's no cutscenes no
cutscenes no story actually there is a
pure gameplay I played it it's not good
what
I'm pretty sure it's Swedish or some
[ __ ] too I don't know you guys make good
games right Minecraft you like oh yeah
yeah I don't know I knew I wouldn't like
it too much and I'm not gonna do it so
for jumping yeah okay let's get it
this is pure stuff it's really good it's
really one of my favorite games
genuinely I believe it
that's like the nice equivalent yeah
exactly I'm still a bit stuck on this
console versus pixie thing because I I
don't get it
what do you mean
a bottle of this if you have gaming
computers why would you not play on them
because I hate sitting in front of my
computer playing games everything does
run better and it looks much better it's
cleaner you can do other [ __ ] just don't
really care okay do you subscribe
because these guys just don't believe it
I'm like I think the better
higher refresh rate monitors are like
amazing yeah they look so good yeah and
they just think I'm talking out of my
ass and I'm like 100 if you guys have
been brainwashed to be honest no
definitely so much difference I bought
one just because this guy wouldn't shut
up about it and I tried and I'm like
there's no [ __ ] difference yeah yeah
I made sure he's like he's like there's
no for me just just for the fail safe
and I play he's like there's no
difference what are you talking about
playing professional novel of cards no
just like like I tried every like all
sorts of different games I'm like okay
different games I like moved it over to
my other monitor just to see the
difference and I'm like there's no [ __ ]
have you talked about this on the
podcast yeah yeah
because these both agree with it and I'm
here alone being like yeah they're like
I'm a clown and it's like no way none of
the games I play is like no chance yeah
for one I think it might have to be like
the the games that I'm playing right
even like RuneScape looks better in
144hz
refresh rate
because to me it's like how can you not
it's like it's like I it's like having a
rock for a mouse and then going to an
actual Mouse it's like so much
difference oh my God all right well okay
go going back to console versus PC yeah
okay all right okay okay so they can't
win right okay look I I won a game on
like a big TV I want to put my feet up
yeah you can't just have like a massive
[ __ ] monitor right you can't just
have a TV
I used to have an ultra wide or you have
three monitors or two right I got three
yeah there you go I just want one big
monitor which is the TV
yeah that I also watch movies and films
on an anime and I just sit back in my
comfort zone
for media gaming is
gaming is literal media I want one
monitor that's a TV that's so good yeah
you can plug it into your computer yeah
my I've had a friend who had a PC in his
living room I mean you could plug it
into your computer but at that point
it's just a [ __ ] hassle because like
you know you [ __ ] got a login and
you've got to like load up again
yeah I just want to press one button
games there all right I can game I can
game yeah I want to relax we got Gamers
too okay console gamers are Gamers too
and we're we're tired of being oppressed
these boys have like the top of the line
PCS yeah that's the thing I understand
like well that's just privation related
only affording a console but like once
you get to that PC stage There's No
Going Back you gotta Taste of sweet
Heaven I don't know man I agree I mean
I'm on PC for days I fully believe this
is like a fish just like it's like it's
like when they Port games to like mobile
I'm like don't don't yeah don't okay no
I'm not that psychotic where I'm like
Yay on mobile but like you know
I mean I guess yeah I get it but I'm
also that guy who's just like I see
something in 1080 and I see something in
4k and I'm like there's a difference but
also I don't care I don't really care
that much you know that's why it's weird
because I do agree with that but gaming
is so different I think that's a
question there's definitely a noticeable
difference okay so how you feel about
the difference between 1080 and 4K is
how I feel better
okay there's a difference but it's not
remarkable
I'm like does it enhance my gaming
experience not really
that's what I'm saying it has to be a
fetish no no it's not even don't
fetishize it yeah it is it's genuinely
it's genuinely extreme Gamers will do
this and be like oh
that's okay you're not a gamer oh
if that doesn't make me a gamer then I'm
not a game all right we need to find
Middle Ground here because it's getting
a little yeah this is trash types
you've watched enough
I don't like being part of it I like
watch it